a new working week and this isn't the
normal london morning gridlock the fuel
station here ran dry two days ago it's
been waiting for this moment
tanker drivers are in short supply not
the fuel whatever the results the same
misery for some not panic buying
ada babatopchi ran out of fuel 100
meters from the petrol pumps after a
search that started in the early hours
and i was very emotional so i can't i
cried
i cried with all these it's
absolutely unnecessary
i cried and i feel so emotional i think
probably lots of people going through a
similar way lives disrupted this driving
instructor trying to get fuel to prepare
his learners for their driving tests
i've got about five six tests coming up
between now and next week
so i was really and truly terrified what
might happen
for this guy's test so i've been going
around like headless chicken around
london
nothing
an opinion poll suggests that more than
60 percent of voters feel the government
is mishandling the situation and some of
the messaging from ministers isn't
helping the public mood
the only reason that we have an issue at
the moment with
some petrol stations not having pets on
the forecourts is that people are buying
petrol and they wouldn't the most
important thing everyone can do is just
get back to normal fill their cars up as
they normally would
and not buy petrol unless they need it
it would seem to be wishful thinking
that this crisis is going to go away
without government action crisis what
crisis has been the government's stance
up to now now it's changing because
people don't like being referred to as
panic buyers in a situation such as this
there is a tide of public descent
and so the pressure is on the government
as the tension on the four courts
increases some companies have introduced
rationing competition measures have been
stopped so that fuel companies can
cooperate on logistics
another move the government has made is
to try backing up uk tanker drivers with
foreigners no longer able to work here
because of brexit
short-term visas are available for 5 000
foreign truck drivers it isn't
guaranteed to work andrew simmons al
jazeera london
well earlier i spoke to tom reddy he's a
lorry driver and also a transport
consultant at green candle traction he
says the uk's temporary visa scheme is
an option but that it's simply not
enough
we've always had an aging generation of
truck drivers in in this country the
younger demographic aren't taking up the
positions because it's not particularly
appealing in terms of the working hours
and the poor conditions pay does pay
play a part in it but it's not the whole
story we do expect a lot from our from
our truck drivers in the uk and we need
to start looking at the overall
structure of the role and the structure
of the industry to see
because it otherwise if nothing changes
there's not going to be a future for
truck drivers in the uk it's not a job
people want to do in the 21st century
it's a difficult situation but the
writing has been on the wall for the
transport industry for for 10 15 years
or more in terms of the shortage
the build the build up to brexit again
that was we could see what was coming
around the corner and the industry had
been quite vocal in what they were
concerned about
and uh now we're seeing very very acute
effects the eye of the storm if you like
um with the situation there's no easy
way out and there's no quick fix and
what we're doing now in terms of the
measures taken the visa situation talk
of the armed forces supporting it's all
very very
questionable about where we go from here